por primera vez en varios meses la
bandera azul y amarilla ondean las
afueras del imán
es primero de octubre desplegamos
nuestra bandera nacional y la izamos en
nuestra tierra en limón será ucraniano
en estas imágenes facilitadas por el
jefe de gabinete del presidente celenski
estos dos soldados simbolizan El Avance
de las fuerzas ucranianas estas han
entrado tras el abandono de las tropas
rusas de la localidad en la región de
doniach el Ministerio de defensa
ucraniano festejó el logro de los
soldados de kiev en esta ciudad
estratégica el portavoz de las fuerzas
ucranianas en el este dijo que el imán
es crucial porque es el siguiente paso
hacia la liberación del dombas ucraniano
y es muy importante psicológicamente los
cerca de 5000 soldados rusos
estacionados en liman han abandonado la
ciudad una retirada que podría marcar
una nueva etapa en el este de Ucrania la
posición del imán en el norte de la
provincia de doniach la convierte en un
punto clave en la estrategia de Ucrania
para recuperar el dombas kiev planea
utilizar la ciudad para avanzar hacia el
este con severodonias tomada por las
fuerzas rusas en junio tras una terrible
batalla en el punto de mira la captura
del imán significa un gran revés para el
kremlin y muestra la fragilidad del
control de Moscú sobre estos territorios
anexionados